>>Catherine Eng: Hi everyone.
Welcome.
I'm Catherine Eng.
I'm on the Authors at Google team, at Google
Los Angeles.
I'm very, very excited to welcome chef David
Chang and Peter Meehan today at Google Los
Angeles.
David Chang is the executive chef and owner
of the Momofuku Restaurant Group which spans
eight restaurants from New York City to Sydney
and soon Toronto.
Since opening the Noodle Bar in 2004, Dave
has been honored with numerous awards from
Food and Wine Magazine, Bon Appetit, GQ Man
of the Year, and of course, three James Beard
awards, and two Michelin stars.
Dave's first cookbook, Momofuku, was published
in 2009.
And he launched Lucky Peach, a quarterly food
journal, last summer.
Peter Meehan is also here today.
He writes about food.
He wrote for the New York Times for four years
and has written for numerous food and travel
publications.
Peter collaborated with Dave on Momofuku,
the cookbook and he and Dave launched Lucky
Peach last year.
In conjunction with McSweeney's.
Today's conversation will be moderated by
our own chef Michael Brown.
And if you haven't already, make sure you
grab a copy of Lucky Peach and try one of
Momofuku Milk Bar's cookies that we're serving
today.
And without further ado, I give you David
and Peter.
[applause]
>>Dave: Thanks for havin'us.
Thanks guys.
Strange, I was telling Kat that we've been,
I think.
I think I've been to every Google office in
North America.
[laughter] And this is by far the most, you
have the beach right here.
This is amazing.
But we're really honored to be here and always
happy to share our stories.
And there's so many things to talk about.
In terms of what we do and Peter and I do.
And one of the stories we'd like to share
with you, a couple years ago, when we started
to do Lucky Peach, it was actually supposed
to be an app.
Still may be an app, but it was in purgatory
and Peter decided to make a magazine out of
the stuff that never made it to the, you know,
the final cut.
So, this whole weird magazine sort of happened.
>>Peter: Everyone thought it was a terrible
idea.
>>Dave: It was a terrible idea.
It still is a terrible idea.
>>Peter: This is true.
>>Dave: Anyway, one of the things that people
always want us to talk about is our time in
Kyoto.
In Japan in general.
But our time in Kyoto, because it's a part
of Japan in the culinary world that not that
many people know about.
Kyoto probably has the oldest and richest
culinary culture in the world.
You know, I was fortunate enough four years
ago to be invited by the Chef Murata-san.
He is like this kingly figure in Japanese
cuisine.
Scares the hell out of me.
Peter thinks he's a really nice guy.
He is a nice guy.
But he commands this presence.
Anyway, he invited myself, two chefs from
the UK, Claude Bosi, Sat Bains, that are actually
in the current issue of Lucky Peach.
And Mike Anthony, the chef at Gramercy Tavern.
And Mauro Colagreco, a chef from Mirazur in
Menton, France.
On the border of France and Italy.
In the region of Nice.
Anyway, we got to cook at various restaurants
and that was such a honor.
Because Kyoto is extraordinarily insular.
They're not necessarily xenophobic but they
don't wanna share their, historically they
haven't shared what they've learned over literally
thousands, fifteen hundred years of cooking.
And you get to work at these restaurants where
they do stuff that you have never seen before.
And we had access to it and were learning
this stuff.
And we were the first foreigners to actually
see what was going on.
Working in a restaurant that is over 1,000
years old.
I don't, it's crazy.
If you're in a 300 year old restaurant, that's
considered young.
To meet a chef, you know, Murata's like the
head of this whole group there.
To meet a chef where he's a 15th generation
chef.
His family's been cooking for over 1,000 years.
And to meet a farmer that they work with who's
also a 15th generation farmer.
His family's been farming for over 1,000 years.
And you know, I didn't do my homework.
But I can't imagine, maybe there's a handful
of farmers in the world that have that lineage.
And it was quite fascinating.
He's somebody that forgets more about farming
than we'll ever know about farming.
And we're there in December, and it's snowing,
and had the best strawberry I ever had in
my life.
I don't know how the hell he did it.
But he just knew.
And he knew, this farmer knew, how each strawberry
was gonna taste in the different parts of
his greenhouse.
So there's this extraordinarily rich culinary
tradition and they allowed us in.
And I told Pete, you know, if we get a chance,
let's go to Kyoto.
And we got permission from Murata to film
at Kikunoi.
And
>>Peter: Eat at Kikunoi.
My main memory of Kikunoi was that Dave and
I are usually dressed like this.
So I just rolled to Kikunoi kinda dressed
like this.
And I didn't realize what a formal and beautiful
restaurant it was.
And he wore this like, hand tailored suit
you'd get in a GQ photo shoot.
And then Murata kinda
>>Dave: Laughed at you.
>>Pete: Yeah.
So that was my takeaway from dinner.
>>Dave: But it's, there's so many interesting
things about Kyoto 'cause it's'a bit different.
I'm sure some of you have spent time in Tokyo.
Having lived there in Japan in various parts.
But whenever I get to Kyoto, it's almost like
a break from the insanity that is Tokyo.
And actually I've been to your Tokyo offices
[laughs] in Google.
But it's crazy.
Because the chefs there are like alpha males
in this society.
It's very weird.
I've never been to a culture where being a
cook is like the highest honor.
Because it's just been passed down and it's
something that's so hard for any of us or
a cook for us, to understand and comprehend
that cooking has remained this high craft
form.
And you know, it's not bankers.
It's not people who work at Google who are
really like the superstars of Kyoto.
It's very strange to see it as chefs.
And you know, eating a meal there, at Kikunoi.
Has anyone been to Kyoto and been to Kikunoi?
OK.
So.
It's pretty intense and one of the cool things
that they do at Kikunoi is that they have
a fish shop.
They purchase fish, and on the compound of
Murata's compound at Kikunoi where all the
cooks live, 27 cooks.
His mother and his two daughters, all live
in the compound.
And part of the compound they have a, what
looks like a very nice aquarium but it is
almost, it's really not good to be a fish.
It's a process called "ikejime."
We talk about it a little bit in the last,
>>Pete: Issue Two.
>>Dave: Issue Two of Lucky Peach.
And there we question.
And this is the first time where I started
to question food and the status quo of food.
'Cause you just assume that fish is fresh.
When you get it at the supermarket or.
>>Pete: And fresh is best.
>>Dave: And fresh fish is best.
You assume that catching a fish right out
of the water, it's going to be the best fish.
You hear all the time, like, I want the freshest
fish.
Or you're at a sushi restaurant and you hear
some yahoo being like, "This fish isn't fresh
enough."
Like, to, you don't even think about what
the concept of "fresh" is.
It's been handed down to you.
Even if your innate instinct is to like, shy
away from it because it may smell bad or something.
Maybe that is fresh.
"Fresh" is certainly not, it's very relative.
But at the same time it's pretty objective
if you think about how the Japanese view what
"fresh" is.
And this is probably the main thing that I
learned.
One of the major things that I've learned
in Kyoto was questioning what is "fresh".
Because there, they have these fish in the
tanks.
Either, and they're gonna perform ikejime
is the severing of the brain cortex and all
the nervous system from the fish and basically
long story cut short, it slows and controls
the rigor mortis process.
So, Japanese chef, in Kyoto, where you serve
it sashimi or something.
Mostly as sashimi.
You can control the flavor and the texture
of the fish.
And there's a optimal time.
And it's not usually
>>Pete: Right out of the water.
>>Dave: Yeah.
Not out of the water.
If you eat, most of the time if you eat sushi,
or crudo in a restaurant.
Its'at least four or five days old.
Sometimes it can go all the way to two weeks.
But you wanna age the fish.
And there's a moment where that fish is going
to be at its peak.
And you can, using different culinary techniques,
you can either preserve that fish to ensure
that sweet spot.
Or you know, basically it threw my entire
notion of what "fresh" is.
I always knew that if you have to ask the
question "What is a fresh fish?"
It's not fresh.
>>Pete: But the thing is, that fresh isn't
actually a metric for deliciousness.
And that's what you learned at, with Murata-san
at Kikunoi.
Where you learned about ikejime where you
like, spike the fish in the brain and then
you drive a wire through its spine.
>>Dave: And it seems really gruesome.
But it's actually an extraordinarily humane
way to kill a fish.
>>Pete: That versus, you know, cutting open
the gills and letting it bleed out on ice
and asphyxiate.
So it's a faster way of death.
But it short-circuits the natural, you know,
the more common, the rigor mortis process
that fish go through here.
So it's a way of controlling the texture of
the fish which is really important in a raw
fish preparation . Because otherwise, you
know, you have no other way of manipulating
it.
And then the other thing we saw when we were
in Tokyo at a Sawada, he ages, this is this
insane sushi restaurant where we had this
brilliant meal.
But he ages his tuna ten days in the refrigerator.
And it was the most amazing tuna we'd ever
had.
And he doesn't like modern refrigerators 'cause
they have fans in them.
So he has like a huge block of ice.
>>Dave: it's as old school as you get.
>>Pete: It's a big, yeah.
You know, 'cause
>>Dave: If he could have
>>Pete: That would dry out his fish.
>>Dave: If he could have no electricity in
his restaurant, he would do that.
Behind his sushi line, which was just him
and his wife, six seats.
It's just charcoal and block ice refrigeration.
And I think it's the, for me, it's my favorite
sushi restaurant in the world.
And that's a whole 'nother issue.
Topic.
But a lot of people question his rice, 'cause
he doesn't use aged rice.
He uses fresh rice.
But Sushi Sawada, if you ever get to Tokyo,
please try to make a reservation 'cause it's
just fantastic.
But overall, Pete and I get to, we're in this
really amazing situation.
Very fortunate to travel all over the place.
To come to places like Google or to go to
places like Japan.
And to get access to places where most people
wouldn't get access.
You know.
We're very fortunate in that regard.
Or we get to go to Copenhagen and get to cook
with Rene Redzepi all day long at Noma. which
is for the third year in a row won the best
restaurant of the year and number one restaurant
in the world from Restaurant Magazine.
So it's part of it is just for us to have
fun and to document this process.
And then sharing this information with people
that might be interested.
Which is what Lucky Peach was and continues
to be.
You know, Pete just wrapped up the latest
issue called America.
We did an issue on American food.
And somehow we continue to get the ability
to do whatever the hell we want.
I mean, Pete you can talk about the latest
issue.
>>Pete: Yeah, we, Daniel Patterson from Coi
in San Francisco suggested the theme.
Like American cuisine, whatever that is.
So we typically we agree on a theme and then
we get in a fight about how to approach it
and then take that out in a couple different
ways.
But this new one, I don't know, we've gotten
really lucky with contributors.
David Simon who did Treme and The Wire, contributed
an essay.
Wrote about Cambodian donut shops in California.
>>Dave: And really the question is, what is
American food?
I mean, so, we took a weird perspective on
it.
I, we did a lot of different takes on it but
one of them was based on the movie "Diner."
Barry Levinson directed it in 1984.
And I think it's Steve Gutenberg's finest
hour.
And it's, you know, it's sort of a look into
Americana in the 1950's and we did an entire
issue out of it, basically.
So we get to have fun and creatively we get
to do whatever we want in that regard.
But part of it was, we get to explore questions.
I think I recently described, or was telling
somebody about Lucky Peach.
It's a "culinary investigation of the mundane."
Because I think the best ideas, culinary ideas
or non-culinary ideas, happen to be the ones
that are staring you right in the face.
People, I'm always trying to find this reaction
from somebody that reads something or tastes
something and they, I want them to go like
this.
They're like "Why didn't I think of that?
That's so simple!
Why didn't I do that?"
That's what we're sort of after, that sort
of illusive, very simple but deceivingly complex
idea or food.
And you know, trying to, Peter does an amazing
job in capturing that, I think.
And we try to do it on the food end and going
back to the American theme, we were trying
to figure out what the hell American food
is.
So, it's just, it's neither here nor there.
I think that people don't even know how to
describe it.
So I think it's, there's this generation of
chefs, are really trying to figure out what
California food, not Californian food, but
what American food is.
Like California has a distinct cuisine.
The southern, the south of America, southern
states in America have a distinct cuisine.
Even New England has a distinct cuisine.
But nobody wants to cook it.
Nobody wants to delve into it and figure out
what the history is behind it.
And how do we represent what we do in America?
And find our own voice.
And I, it's a little bit troublesome when
we imitate so much of what's going on outside
of America and try to bring it back to America.
And I think that we have enough talent, we
have enough resources, and we have enough
savvy consumers like yourselves that come
to our restaurants to, you know, further the
American culinary talent.
Like, American cuisine is this melting pot.
And we're not reflecting that enough.
So, it's our challenge.
It's our struggle to sort of push that a little
bit further and to find out what that is.
So, I mean, you can't really decide what it
is.
I mean, we recently opened a restaurant in
Sydney and you know, I posed a question to
the journalists, like "What is Sydney cuisine?"
And they're like "It's everything."
And I was like, "Well."
'Cause they were trying to pigeonhole us into
what kind of food we were gonna cook.
And I said, "Instead of trying to figure out
what kind of food we're going to cook and
categorizing it so it can be in some Zaga
guide or some blog.
Like this is Asian food, this is French food.
I think the most important thing that we need
to be concerned about is, how delicious is
it?
Who cares what kind of food it is, as long
as it's really tasty?
Does it bring joy to you when you leave the
restaurant and you think about it?
That to me is the most important thing."
And I think that's what we need to find in
America.
Is like, what is delicious in America and
how do we support that and how do we further
that.
So.
>>Pete: I'm gonna defer to him on questions.
>>Michael: Well, first of all, I mean, this
is an amazing opportunity to have both of
you here.
And talking about Lucky Peach, I've started
reading Lucky Peach.
And the first thought I got was just how candid
the writing was.
You could really speak to chefs.
You know, it was a great voice, when you're
talking about the PTSD part about our, our,
consistently stressful lives.
And what it takes to really get into making
it or not in this industry.
So, I think I could say on behalf of a lot
of chefs, "Thank you for this publication."
First question we have is, Lucky Peach envelopes
a lot of great writing, a lot of art, a lot
of graphics.
What was the inspiration for that?
And did you find that it's hard to maintain
a color, full color publication when there's
truly not a lot of that still happening now?
>>Pete: Yeah.
We were making, we were shooting video to
put into an app, and that is in some sort
of limbo sarcophagus right now.
But I like buying records and books and physical
media.
So, and we have friends at McSweeney's who
we had wanted to work with for years, and
when they heard about it, we cooked up this
idea for a magazine.
And it just worked somehow.
And it continued.
>>Dave: We really wanted to do new media.
>>Pete: You really wanted to do new media.
I wanted to do dead media.
[inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Dave: Yeah.
It's funny how that works out.
We literally are doing the oldest, most deadest
form of media possible.
>>Pete: Yeah.
Yeah.
>>Michael: The term "fusion cuisine" went
through a "dirty word" phrase with foodies
and now it's in vogue again thanks to the
great chefs like you and Roy Choi and Sang
Yoon.
What do you make of this change?
How come everybody still who's the leaders
in this fusion, this new fusion is Korean.
How does that work out.
>>Dave: I don't know.
You know it's great to see in LA, like, people
always come back to New York and are like
"Man, their Asian food was so fucking awesome."
And it is.
You can eat so well here.
Even if you just go to Chinatown or Korea
Town.
Or, I think, I don't know why the Vietnamese
or Southeast Asian food, there's no "Thai
Town" or "Vietnamese Town" here.
[audience murmurs]
Is there?
>>Pete: Yeah, very small.
>>Dave: [inaudible] I know there's an amazing
one out in Orange County.
Like past Alto there.
But
>>female audience member: There's all kinds
of "towns" around here.
>>Dave: Yeah.
So you guys have the ethnic food down in spades.
And I just think that it's just reached a
point where a lot of cooks want to just do
what they wanna do.
And not necessarily for the customer, but
what's delicious and what's interesting to
them.
You see that with Roy.
You see that obviously with Sang.
You see that in California with the Mission
Street Chinese guys.
And I think the more we have of that, the
more it, it's not necessarily fusion.
It certainly is "fusion" in, I mean, I just
hate the concept of people trying to categorize
something that, you know, isn't.
Basically, Roy, if you take one of anybody
that's cooking, whatever type of food, using
some type of Asian ingredients.
If you take a chef from New York that's French.
You know, Jean-Georges is using more Asian
ingredients than say, Roy is.
But because Roy is Korean, he's labeled as
this Korean-American chef that's doing this
fusion cuisine.
But nobody's every gonna ever say anything
against Jean-Georges who, I admire.
I'm not talking crap about Jean-Georges.
I'm talking about how he's perceived and how
he's marketed to the public.
He's this great French chef that has this
repertoire of Asian ingredients in his arsenal.
He's cooking French food with an Asian twist.
And one sounds better than the other.
And one seems like this weird hodge-podge,
mutant food.
But the reality, it's the same thing.
Right?
People are using ingredients from different
cultures.
One's accepted.
And one is a "fledgling concept."
So I’m all for change, as long as it sort
of furthers, again, trying to make something
better.
And I think it again, just the word "fusion"
and the word of trying to categorize stuff,
ultimately fails.
So.
>>Michael: in Lucky Peach Number Two, you
allude to the "sweet spot."
Also known as when someone's at their best
moment.
Do you still worry about that?
Is that still part of your daily thought process?
>>Dave: Yeah.
Yeah.
[chuckles] You know, I like sports a lot.
And when, like the Lakers are on, and they're
like "Oh, Kobe Bryant is turning 34, this
is his last year as a Laker.
The Lakers didn't make it to the finals.
He's over, it's done."
And I'm like "Fuck man."
[laughs] You know?
But I don't think that people like to embrace
the concept of not death, per se, but just
slow descent to where they're not gonna be
as good as they once were.
And I tend to be, I tend to focus on that
quite a bit.
And I think it's liberating in a way because
if you know that everything has its peak and
everything.
Everything begins and everything dies.
And somewhere along the way you're going to
be better at something than you were in the
past.
And you know, I think a lot of people, particularly
chefs, never really think about it.
Chefs, we're the most stubborn.
We're just so fucking stubborn it's ridiculous.
And we think we're going to get better.
We're just always going to get better.
And I see that in athletes.
You know, it's like the quarterback Bret Favre.
Who never wants to retire 'cause he thinks
he's as good as he was when he was 28 years
old.
It's not the case.
And no matter what.
Even if you're in the humanities, you're going
to not be as good as a judge when you were
when you were like 50 years old.
When you're 80 years old, you might not--.
I mean it's just, accepting that fact I think
makes you smarter.
Makes you more efficient in terms of how you
think and how you approach and how you're
creative.
And maybe you may not be as creative, or you
may not endeavor to do as many things as you
did when you were younger.
But you're a smarter player.
You're a smarter chef.
And you may be a better leader.
So instead of being, literally
>>Pete: I really think the relativity of that,
how you can change as you mature is the reason
I don't agree with you that there is a sweet
spot in life.
>>Dave: See, this is where we, uh.
>>Pete: we just
[laughter]
>>Dave: I mean, it all started with.
>>Pete: You thought ramen was a bad idea for
an issue.
>>Dave: But I'm wrong all the time.
I admit it.
You never do.
>>Pete: As am I.
[laughs]
>>Dave: Like, there's a theory that there
will never be another 400 baseball hitter
ever again.
And I don't think there ever will.
But Peter maintains this notion that it's
going to happen.
I think that it's never going to happen.
Not that there isn't the talent to do so,
it's just, never going to happen.
And, you know, I just, I would rather focus
on what we can do now rather than what is,
you know, what is conceivably possible, and,
we're not gonna get into the baseball thing
today right now.
[laughter]
>>Michael: I mean, I really love that you
guys disagree.
You know?
'cause it really comes out in the magazine
and it really brings up you know, discussion
and argument.
And you know, I love that dynamic about Lucky
Peach and you guys.
Going back to the ramen talk.
You know, ramen noodles originated from China
and there are types of noodles.
Soups and dishes in Asian culture.
Different.
But none seem to have captured the American
imagination and appetites as well as ramen
except maybe pho.
Why do you think that is?
What is it about ramen that really, is, romantic.
>>Pete: I mean, I think the impetus to do
an issue on ramen is 'cause there is a great
story.
And it's relatively recent.
Like the last hundred years.
Or when ramen was invented as a dish and became
prominent.
And Momofuku Ando, the man who invented instant
noodles has like a super compelling story.
So there was just a lot of stories behind
it to tell.
Which is the reason we did the issue.
But why ramen is so popular?
I don't know 'cause it's cheap?
And you can eat it in college?
And you know what it is?
And I think there's a gateway drug aspect
and you know what ramen is.
And now you can go to a ramen shop and get
a real bowl of ramen instead of just a brick.
And.
>>Michael: There's also a very social atmosphere
as well.
You can share and talk about it and make noises
eating it.
>>Dave: That's the thing in America.
People in America don't know how to eat noodles.
>>Pete: No, I learned that in Tokyo with Dave.
Because I ate professionally for a brief time
in my life so I thought I was good at eating
noodles.
>>Dave: it's embarrassing to watch Peter eat
>>Pete: And, um.
>>Dave: I'm surprised he knows how to used
chopsticks.
>>Pete: And yeah, we went to ramen shops.
And I just didn't realize you're supposed
to, like, huff the noodles
>>Dave: You're not supposed to talk
>>Pete: while they're like, really hot.
And I was taking my time.
And, like, it was just too shameful.
I was getting like, I was like, little 40-pound
Japanese women were just crushing these bowls
of ramen.
I was like "It's so hot, I just need another
minute."
[laughter] There's a, we don't actually know
how to eat ramen for as much as we like it,
it turns out.
>>Dave: And I would slowly move my seat further
away from Peter.
[Peter laughs]
>>Dave: I'm like "I don't know who this guy
is."
But yeah, you have to eat it smoking, boiling,
hot.
Or the noodles are gonna overcook and I, that's
just never gonna change.
Like, in the first issue we talk about this
I call him the M and M of ramen.
Ivan Orkin.
And this, this New York guy serving basic
Jewish comfort food in the form of ramen to
Japanese people.
It's extraordinarily good ramen and he's trying
to open up something in America.
And you know we're talking about how it's
gonna work.
And I say, "Dude, your ramen.
You're gonna have to change your noodles because
Americans are not going to eat it as they
should.
And they're gonna complain that the noodles
are soggy.
Because by the time they get to the temperature
that they wanna eat it at, it's gonna be overcooked."
So he's like "What should I do?"
I was like "I don't have an answer."
So, yeah.
>>Pete: Yeah.
>>Dave: It's one of those frustrating things.
Little things.
>>Michael: What do you guys think is the most
punk rock thing happening now in food?
>>Dave: Um, for me I think it's'this guy Alex
Stupak in New York.
[coughs] He was a pastry chef at Alinea when
it opened up.
Extraordinarily influential at that restaurant
and the success it had.
And he left to become the pastry chef at wd-50.
Wylie Dufresne's important, such an important
restaurant in New York.
And he was at the vanguard of not just being
one of the best chefs, but pastry chefs.
But one of the few people in the world that
actually created new techniques.
And just in general I think in any field there's
few people that actually create something
new.
Alright?
And he was one that created new techniques
that other chefs would use.
And he's a good friend of ours.
And he was always talking about "I just wanna
cook Mexican food.
I think it's fascinating."
I think because of the internet or whatever
we sort of, I hate using the word "postmodern."
But the cooking world reached this weird state
of, like, what he was doing wasn't "punk rock"
anymore.
Like creating new techniques and sort of being
at the vanguard, was for him, being rebellious.
Breaking down rules and creating his own rules
and when he saw that there were legions of
cooks copying him, and following his rules,
he just thought it was over.
And in a way he was completely correct.
And I thought the coolest thing he could've
ever done was tell everybody "I'm gonna quit
cooking modern cuisine and I'm gonna make
Mexican food."
And people thought he was out of his mind.
He opened up a restaurant called Empellón,
in the West Village and that slowly turned
into Taqueria.
And he recently opened his place called Empellón
Cocina.
And it's his take on Mexican food.
It's more dish-heavy.
And I think it's just fantastic.
It's delicious 'cause Mexican food, we just
don't have a good representation of it in
New York.
And he's doing extraordinarily good things
and it, knowing Alex, , it suits him.
I don't know of anyone that's done anything
as awesome as that.
Sort of like, just turning his back on everything
he knew and relearning.
I think that takes a lot of balls.
So.
>>Pete: I think Brooks Headley who's the pastry
chef at Del Posto.
He just cut a seven-inch record with one of
the dudes from No Age.
And it's actually punk rock.
>>Dave: But he was
>>Pete: Um.
>>Dave: But he is a punk rock.
He was, before he became a pastry chef, he
was in like, hard core punk bands.
So.
>>Pete: Yeah.
>>Dave: that doesn't count.
>>Pete: I don't know.
>>Dave: I mean he really is a rock star.
[laughing]
>>Pete: It was a concise answer.
>>Michael: [laughing] That's awesome.
In the first issue you asked Uneo-san about
his feelings about tradition and authenticity.
What are your feelings about that?
>>Dave: Who do we make fun of?
>>Pete: No, no, no, we asked Uneo-san at Bar
Five.
>>Dave: Oh.
>>Pete: Um, I mean I think, authenticity is
one of those traps that people get caught
up in when they talk about food.
Specifically like ethnic or you know, ethnic
food in America.
It'll always be like "Oh, that place isn't
authentic."
Or "Oh it's all Chinese people there and it's
really authentic."
And it's not.
It's this false measurement instead of like,
appreciating the deliciousness of the food
and judging the restaurant on its own merits.
And I think that what Dave was saying about
categorizing cuisine.
Being less useful that responding to the restaurant
or the food specifically that's being served.
But tradition is, you know, tradition is tradition
and that exists.
Authenticity, I think, is sometimes a false
measurement to judge food by.
Or, you know, it's not, it's used more like
a cudgel than it is like you know a precision
measurement.
>>Dave: I think it's extraordinarily stupid.
[laughter]
>>Pete: That was concise answer.
>>Dave: Yeah, well no.
I mean, it's like we're at this restaurant
getting drinks last night.
And it was "The Best Hamburger Ever!"
That's the name of their hamburger.
And I was like, "This is the dumbest name
I've ever heard."
And just, try, this pursuit of authenticity
again overshadows the pursuit of delicious.
And you know what?
You have restaurants that import people from
Italy.
Entire fucking towns.
>>Pete: To make pasta.
>>Dave: And you know what, they import the
flour.
You know, pasta, there's three ingredients.
Flour, water, eggs.
The water is extraordinarily important.
It is full of microbes, it's full of things
that, the alkaline content could be different.
These are all things that can dramatically
change the taste of pasta.
The structure of pasta.
And people are so caught up in pursuing the
marketing aspect of authenticity.
Like "We serve authentic Italian food."
No, you're not.
You're not in Italy.
Shut the fuck up.
[laughter]
Just think of it vice versa, right?
You've probably been abroad.
Like you go to, let's say, you're in Shanghai.
Right?
And you see some ex-pat serving authentic
New York style pizza.
And your reaction is gonna be what?
No.
That's the dumbest thing I've ever heard.
There's like, you know, soy sauce on the pizza.
What the fuck are you talkin'about?
So that's the thing.
I think it's easier to understand authenticity
when you take a ex-pat's point of view.
It's like, I always use the, 'cause I did
meet a German guy from Munich that wanted
to make American barbecue.
He's like "I'm gonna make it authentic.
It's gonna be just like Memphis style barbecue."
And I was like "No it's not gonna be Memphis
style barbecue.
'cause you're number one not using the beef
that's coming from, any of the meat that's
coming from America.
You're not using any of the wood from America.
You're not even using any of the workers,
the hands, the invisible stuff.
All the things that make something special,
that tastes the way it does at a unique area.
So don't tell anybody you're serving authentic
American barbecue."
>>Pete: And it even goes to how we eat.
It's like the difference between the way we
eat ramen here and the way we eat ramen in
Japan.
If you're not eating it the same way, if you
don't have the same cultural association with
how you relate to that food.
That inhibits the potential for it to be authentically
authentic.
I mean, we both think that authenticity is
kind of like a red herring.
But.
>>Dave: True.
>>Pete: it should be about the deliciousness
of the food.
Not about the story that goes on with it.
>>Dave: I think it's more important instead
of getting the authenticity down is understanding
what the flavors are of a particular region.
And paying respect to that.
And that again, using Alex Stupak as an example.
Here we are in New York and he's cooking food
from various regions of Mexico.
Somebody that has a really encyclopedic knowledge
of flavor profiles of Mexico, but we don't
have the same ingredients.
So he's gonna try to mimic but not copy those
flavors.
And in a way it's not Mexican anymore.
It's New York.
And I think that's really important.
[coughing in background]
>>Michael: I think one question that probably
everyone in this room has is, why is there
not a Momofuku in LA yet?
>>Dave: Wow.
Almost happened like four or five times.
Different people.
It's a sore subject for Peter.
'Cause it almost opened up in his favorite
hotel.
Don't say it, 'cause I'll get in trouble.
>>Peter: OK.
I just coulda stayed there for like, free.
It would have been crazy.
>>Dave: Ahhh.
[laughter]
>>Peter: It's really all about me, our relationship.
>>Dave: I think it'd be tough to open up in
LA.
It's not that I don't like to.
I just think it's a fast food culture.
People have to drive.
People don't drink.
There's like few restaurants that do multiple
turns.
And it's hard enough, and I don't know.
Like, maybe we'll do something but, I knew
it was a bad idea to sort of think about opening
a restaurant in LA just because it would break
up my layover to Australia.
And that's not a good enough reason to open
up a restaurant.
In fact, it's a really, really bad reason.
So as much as I'd like to.
'Cause the produce here is so great.
And I've always maintained that the best restaurants
in the world, at least in America should easily
come from southern California.
I mean, obviously San Francisco.
Just, California just produces amazing things.
So.
That is the draw.
Because the product you get here.
You have tomatoes already.
The salads.
When we got here the first thing we wanted
was "Let's eat salad.
It's so good."
>>Pete: We have like apples and cabbage.
>>Dave: Yeah.
We.
>>Pete: Most of the.
>>Dave: Can't grow apples like we do.
But everything else is pretty amazing, is
really amazing.
So, that's the temptation to open up a restaurant.
Because the produce here is so amazing.
And, but, you know, I'm never gonna say never.
But it's most likely never going to happen.
>>Michael: We'll just have to make those trips.
Harold McGee wrote in one of the Lucky Peach
issues that mold actually enhances some of
the flavor of produce.
Speaking of produce.
And Dave and Pete are doing a lecture tonight
at UCLA.
The Science and Food series about the role
of microbes in our food.
Can we get a little preview of what you will
be talking about tonight.
>>Dave: Mold equals flavor.
Microbes equal flavor.
You don't see it but it does.
And so much of what we're doing right now
at our test kitchen is developing misos and
soy sauce and fermented products.
Vinegars.
All these things that are extraordinarily
delicious, full of umami but are controlled
rot.
And it calls into question again our concept
of what is fresh, what is delicious.
And sorta ties into, well basically a lot
of it circles and hovers around this taboo
subject of MSG.
Which, I think, using some terms from the
UCLA guys, I jokingly say, but sometimes I'm
not joking when I say that it clearly suggests
a form of racism.
>>Pete: The fear of MSG.
>>Dave: Yeah.
Fear of MSG.
Which, people say they're allergic to.
And I'm not saying they're, I just believe
that it happens to be possibly more psychosomatic
than anything else.
'Cause there's nothing that proves that MSG.
In fact, all the studies, there have been
many that are, try to prove that MSG creates
this Chinese Restaurant Syndrome.
There's no evidence at all.
In fact, everything supports that it's psychosomatic.
And we serve Asian food in part, I'm particularly
interested in it because we serve a lot of
Asian ingredients and people say "Oh, I can't
eat your food because there's soy sauce in
it."
But they're happy going to Bobo, eating a
plate of pasta with tomatoes and Parmesan
cheese.
>>Pete: Both of which are ingredients that
are rich in
>>Dave: Glutamic acid, which equals umami.
You know.
And the only difference between that and artificially
made MSG is they add one molecule of sodium
so you can disperse the glutamic acid.
Your body digests and breaks down glutamic
acid the same way as one would eat a bag of
Doritos or anything else.
Soy.
Like, Doritos.
You know, a plate of Parmesan is extraordinarily
high in MSG.
>>Pete: Yeah, one of the ongoing things in
the magazine is campaigning for MSG.
[laughter]
>>Dave: At the very least I. [inaudible] it's
true.
You're making fun of me.
>>Pete: The first issue we had Harold explain
the whole birth of Chinese Restaurant Syndrome
was the title of a letter in the New England
Journal of Medicine that was a question, not
a report.
>>Dave: Written by a Chinese guy.
That sucks.
>>Pete: It's on that dude.
>>Dave: [laughing]
>>Pete: And then we had another article later
about how there are flavor receptors in your
tongue for umami, for glutamic acid.
It's just something interesting.
'Cause it's part of, you know, savoriness.
It tells you the food is good.
So eventually we'll hope to convince people
that MSG is OK.
Which is not to say that we cook, or you cook,
with like, MSG
>>Dave: Oh, no, no, no.
But the question, here's the question: Why
don't we use MSG?
We use all sorts of other ingredients that
people don't have any problem not questioning.
But it's like the most taboo thing you could
possibly add.
And people know nothing about it.
They believe the media.
They believe what's been told to 'em and it's
just one of these things that you know, until
proven otherwise, all facts prove to the contrary.
That MSG's not bad for you.
And it's not that we want to promote MSG.
It's just, let's care about real issues, not
about, you know.
And in a way, that's why I say it may be a
form of racism.
Because, you have people who are like, "I
can't eat this.
I can't eat Chinese food.
Or I can't eat Thai food.
Or I can't eat Korean food."
But they can eat Italian food.
And that pisses me off.
[laughter]
>>Michael: [laughing] Well, I would like to
now open the questions for anyone on the floor
who has questions for them.
And we have a microphone in the back.
You can step up.
>>Dave: No, you can just, we can hear you.
[audience murmuring]
>>Dave: I'll just, I'll just repeat, it'll
be fine.
[inaudible]
>>Dave: Oh yeah?
>>female #1: Hi guys, my name is Jess.
I'm a huge admirer of both of you guys.
I have a couple comments and a question.
Hopefully you won't mind given that much of
my disposable income has gone to fund Momofuku
in New York.
My favorite issue has been the "sweet spot"
issue.
Especially the apricot article.
>>Peter: Adam Gollner?
>>female #1: Yeah, that article.
I think you guys alluded to this earlier.
Pretty much redefined how I defined fresh
fruits.
And I've been lecturing.
My husband's like, "OK, I get it.
We're not gonna get apricots here.
We'll have to fly to Uzbekistan or wherever
it was that you guys featured."
>>Peter: It's really expensive to go to Tajikistan.
And it's a really long flight; there are no
direct routes.
>>female #1: Right.
So I contacted the vendor to see if I can
get some delivered.
But that's ongoing.
Anyway, that was a great article and I've
been also talking to people about the ikejime
and I don't cook as much as I should.
But your recipes is something that I've, you
know, put on my refrigerator just for inspiration.
>>Peter: We do those funny recipe layouts
because we know, I mean, in any cooking magazine
you've ever bought, if you cook one or two
things out of an issue.
You're like, that was useful.
So we just try to make them readable and like,
you know, if you read through it you at least
learn something about it.
Whereas if it was just like a column of text
maybe you wouldn't be motivated to do that.
>>female #1: Great.
And in terms of the restaurants David, I absolutely
loved the shaved foie gras at Coi.
And if you ever get rid of that I will be
very upset.
I heard you have a tendency to take stuff
off your menu once they reach that popularity.
>>Dave: We're lucky that people like that
dish but unlucky that people like it enough
that if we took it off the menu people would
be pissed.
So, um, we sort of have this unwritten rule
where we won't replace a dish unless we can
exceed its deliciousness.
And how people perceive it.
So, we're gonna have that on for a while.
But if we're in California, we'd have to take
it off.
'Cause you have the dumbest legislation ever.
>>female #1: Chicago had it but I think they
had a loophole.
>>Dave: No, they repealed that.
Partly because, I don't know.
It's, I mean, if you guys aren't aware, the
California has banned the sale and consumption
of foie gras.
Which is extraordinarily short sighted I think.
And, you know, there's other issues to, for
anti foie protesters to tackle like commodity
chicken.
That goes to chicken McNuggets and other terrible
things that go into food.
But this is just a ridiculous topic.
Like nobody, like 200,000 people a year consume
foie gras.
It's something ridiculously small.
But it's something that we dealt with in New
York and unfortunately that, the legislators
love.
'Cause it's just their ability to pass this
is their ability to take, to tell voters that
"We care about animal rights and the welfare
and the environment."
'Cause it's such a nonsensical topic that
nobody really cares about.
So it's a pyrrhic victory for them.
>>female #1: Yeah.
And in terms of non controversial foods.
Your kimchi at Noodle Bar.
As a fellow Korean.
Quite proud.
Your mother must be very proud.
>>Dave: She thinks it's too salty.
>>female #1: She says it's too salty?
I ate the entire jar by myself.
I hate admitting that, but I did it.
And your wait staff kinda stared at me.
>>Dave: I'm glad you enjoyed it.
>>female #1: And then finally my question
is, I know you spend a lot of time outside
of the kitchen now and my question to you
is, how do you still stay involved with all
the different restaurants that you guys have
around the world.
>>Dave: Man.
Living out of a suitcase.
No, we have a lab.
It's a struggle.
And I'm sure that if you asked Larry Page
and Serge of Google like how the hell do you
guys keep the spirit of Google alive as you
guys have grown into this massive company?
Right?
It's not as, it's not the upstart that it
once was right?
How do you maintain that philosophy to stoke
the fire, to stoke creativity, to stoke people
to be excited and work for Google.
And I think that's the struggle that I'm always
trying to figure out.
I don't have that answer.
'Cause we do have so many employees.
I never thought I'd get to a point where I
don't know anyone's name.
I just don't.
it's too hard.
And not too hard, it's impossible.
So, it's a work in progress.
As everything is.
So.
>>female #1: Thank you.
>>Pete: Yeah, and check out, Adam wrote a
book called The Fruit Hunters.
Which if you liked that article, you will
enjoy.
>>female #2: Hi, I've a question for Dave.
In the most recent issue of Lucky Peach, you
warned that dark days are coming in the culinary
world.
>>Dave: Yeah.
>>female #2: Can you tell us more about what
you think about that and do you mainly attribute
that to the Food Network, that celebrity type
of culture that has pervaded the world?
Culinary schools?
Or, just things are different now?
>>Dave: Things are different now.
And I don't think you can attribute, I'm pretty
pessimistic, not pessimistic.
>>Pete: Yeah.
>>Dave: I'm pretty pessimistic.
[laughter] About the future of the culinary
world.
Particularly fine dining.
I don't necessarily love fine dining.
It's not that I don't love it, I don’t'wanna
eat it every day.
I think that it's extraordinarily important
that we continue to have the intensity of
fine dining.
To teach cooks.
So the loss of fine dining restaurants.
The loss of, how should I say?
I use this as an example a lot.
Like if you were an actor, if you were a star
football player in high school, you sort of
know what's at the end of the tunnel if you
happen to be successful at it.
You know that there's fame and fortune and
media, whatever.
So you're a bit prepared for it.
When I started to cook, or the generation
before me.
And obviously everyone before that, that never
existed.
You just cooked and maybe one day you were
gonna be good enough to have your own restaurant.
If somebody was lucky enough to give you that
opportunity.
Now, with the internet and with TV, you can't
blame cooks, but now that option is available
to them.
So like an athlete, they know that if they
happen to be good at it.
Or not even good at it.
They're going to be able to gain some notoriety
or fame and it's changed everything.
And the 40 hour work week has changed everything
as well.
You know, I think that I was talking to the
head of Brown University's medical department.
And he was saying, I was asking, are we producing
better doctors now than we were in the past?
And he said, "No." [laughs] Basically, no.
He didn't think so.
Not necessarily that they're worse.
Kids aren't less intelligent or less motivated.
It's just that systems change.
You know.
They're more concerned about life-work balance.
And when he was a medical resident, you worked
100, 120 hours a week.
And like two, three day shifts.
Now, it's regimented like eight, ten hours
a day.
Even if you wanted to go work 100 hours a
week at a hospital you wouldn't be allowed
to particularly because of the insurance.
And the liability that you could murder, I
mean, you could accidentally kill somebody.
And you know, I've spoken to other, you know,
professionals, like a very well known person
in the medical field.
And she basically said it's a good thing.
You know.
That cooks, not cooks, that doctors aren't
working those hours.
Because it causes fatigue and it's not good.
But the one agreement that I have I think
from these two esteemed gentlemen.
Is that the medical profession is that they
feel that you lose intuition.
You lose the ability to know how to cook.
And one of 'em was like, "Everybody wants
to become a ophthalmologist.
And a specialized doctors.
Nobody wants to become a surgeon anymore."
Partly because there's a system in place that
makes them better.
The technology makes the doctors better and
then they actually are.
And I feel that if that's happening at the
highest level of education in this country,
why wouldn't it affect what I don't, it's
not the lowest but, a field that is certainly
lower in craftsmanship and skill than being
a medical doctor.
There's certainly a lot more to know and to
do.
And if that's affecting the highest field,
why wouldn't it affect the culinary field.
So if you just really look at, the hours you're
supposed to work, I think that's really put
a, you can't learn how to cook in 40 hours
a week.
You can't.
Can you guys do your job in 40 hours a week?
>>audience member: Less.
>>Dave: Less?
[laughs] for most people, you can't.
But you guys are on salary and Google makes
a ton of money.
Right?
And but for the most part, cooking, you don't
make a lot of money.
So you have to be able to, you gotta work
more.
And you do it for the love of it, and if you're
unable to work more.
I don't know how much, right?
But I think it's really important for cooks
that are starting out to really immerse themselves
in it as much as possible.
And right now we have system in culinary culture
that prohibits that.
So things are changing.
And for that reason, I'm pessimistic.
So it's not, I've nothing against younger
cooks.
And just whatever they call them, the millennial
generation?
It's not their fault.
It's the, we, somebody has to figure out,
devise a better way to teach.
And that's our job as chefs and cooks.
We have to teach.
And it's becoming more and more difficult
to teach.
And I'll just add one more thing.
We have a lab and we're doing, I think, some
cool stuff with fermentation and new techniques.
And just learning is a good thing.
And I had a cook that was like "Hey!" he was
talking to the head of the lab.
And he's like "I wanna, I would love to learn
how, what you guys are working in the lab."
And they were like "Come in on Wednesday,
we have open office hours, we'd love to teach
you, tell you what we're doing."
He's like "That's my day off, can't do that."
[laughs]
You know, and if you don't have the, we can't
force them to do it.
We can, I don't know.
I'm actually, completely flabbergasted and
trying to figure out how to encourage people
to want to learn more.
And to want to be passionate about cooking.
And it's something that I love a lot.
And I care a lot about.
And it's extraordinarily troublesome to me
to, I think it should, you know, people should
be excited about it on their own.
They would want to learn.
But I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
>>female #2: That's a very pessimistic view.
[laughter]
>>Dave: Well.
>>male #1: What's the 40 hour work week in
kitchens.
'Cause that's not something I've ever heard
of being reality before.
>>Dave: Well, the 40 hour work week usually
in New York and even in California, you work
40 hours, then after 40 hours you get overtime.
In California, I think it's like two and a
half?
What is it?
>>Michael: time and a half.
>>Dave: That's crazy.
The margins in a restaurant are so small.
And it's so hard, just staffing out a restaurant.
And then if you have to pay a cook time and
a half and give 'em like a lunch break.
It's crazy.
You need people to work.
Kitchens don't have the luxury of over-staffing.
>>male #1: Well when you came up it was "Shift
A", right?
>>Dave: Yes.
Basically, worked.
>>male #1: So is there like a shift between,
like, do restaurants don't do shift pay anymore.
They do hourly pay.
>>Dave: Well, shift pay is illegal.
>>male #1: I mean I know some line cooks and
they don't work even close to 40 hours weeks.
>>Dave: I'm not saying everyone does.
Alright?
But for the most part it's headed that direction.
And again, if you step away from what we're
at.
'Cause the culinary world and everything that's
happening is happening at such a rapid pace
I don't think we have the perspective to really
see what the hell's happening.
We don't have the time frame to have reflection
of what is happening.
So you have to look at other cultures.
Look at what happened to Europe with the 40
hour, I think it was 36 hour work week.
It literally killed dining in France.
I mean.
There are restaurants that continue to employ
people and work at longer hours but for the
most part, if you have the majority of country
or the majority of an industry working a set
set of hours, it eventually diminishes the
talent pool.
It diminishes your workforce.
And now, not everybody does.
But maybe there, are they hourly employees,
your friends.
>>male #1: I actually am not sure.
>>Dave: That's where you have
[audience member calls out something]
>>Dave: You have a sous chef and you work
a lot.
You work a lot of hours.
>>female #2: I'm going to end it with a more
optimistic question.
I have an 11 pound Mangalitsa pork shoulder
in my refrigerator right now.
What would you recommend I do with it.
Should I just make a balsam?
>>Dave: It's a really easy recipe.
And
>>Female #2: I know.
>>Dave: And Mangalitsa is a type of pig from
Germany, I believe?
>>Pete: Is that the furry pig?
>>Dave: The furry one?
>>female #2: From Hungary.
>>Dave: It's like a woolly, yeah, Hungary.
And it's got extraordinarily well marbled
fat in it.
And it's just delicious type of pig.
And, it was like a lost breed or something
and it came back.
And it's really expensive so yeah, I'd throw
a party.
[laughter]
>>female #2: But when there's so much fat,
like, the simpler the better.
Right?
And that's why I thought of the balsam recipe.
>>Dave: Well, there's only so much you can
do with a pork shoulder, right?
'Cause, its'a little bit sinewy.
Like you could slice it thin enough to cook
like thin steaks of it.
But for the most part you need to cook it,
if you're gonna cook it whole, long enough
where, you know, the sinew and some of the
muscle tissue is gonna break down.
And that's how you're gonna get that sort
of braised meat sensation.
>>female #2: And do you have any tips that's
not in your cookbook for that recipe.
>>Pete: So, it's simple.
And stew.
Just salt, sugar.
>>Dave: Yeah.
>>female #2: So I can't screw it up.
>>Dave: You can.
But the likelihood of it happening is pretty
low.
>>Pete: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Dave: Especially you know, just put it in,
and six, seven hours later, 300 degrees.
You should be ready to go.
Even if it's 11 pounds.
>>female #2: Alright.
I'll throw a party.
Thank you.
>>Dave: thank you guys.
>>Pete: Thanks for having us.
[applause]